Elle a été trois fois de suite championne régionale
à Shaolin Kempo.
A neuf ans, elle est à mi-chemin de la ceinture noire.
Ma fille est athlétique.
Quand un homme faisant 1,90m et 120 kg se tient devant vous
et dit que sa fille est athlétique,
vous pourriez penser qu'elle lui ressemble.
Ce n'est pas le cas.
(Rires)
Au lycée, ma femme a été deux fois championne régionale de football
et deux fois championne régionale de volley-ball
alors que je jouais à « Donjons et Dragons ».
C'est pour cela que,
bien que ma fille soit une athlète,
c'est aussi une geek, ce que j'adore.
Elle se promène dans la maison avec une cape de flammes
qu'elle s'est fabriquée.
Elle s'assoit sur le trône de fer --
(Rires)
bien qu'elle n'ait jamais vu « Games of Thrones »,
car nous ne sommes pas les pires parents du monde.
Elle sait qu'il y a quelqu'un s'appelant la mère des dragons
et elle s'appelle ainsi, elle adore.
Elle adore les bandes-dessinées.
Actuellement, son personnage préféré est Groot.
Elle adore Groot.
Elle adore l'incroyable Hulk.
Mais ce qui tient vraiment à cœur à ma fille,
c'est Star Wars.
Mon enfant est un Jedi.
Bien qu'elle soit aussi un Sith,
et c'est un choix que je respecte.
(Rires)
Mais voici la question que je me dois de poser :
pourquoi, quand ma fille se déguise,
que ce soit en Groot ou en l'incroyable Hulk,
Obi-Wan Kenobi ou Dark Maul,
pourquoi est-ce que tous ces personnages sont-ils des garçons ?
Où sont les super-héroïnes ?
Là n'est pas la question,
puisqu'il y a plein de super-héroïnes.
Ma question est : où sont les trucs des super-héroïnes ?
Où sont les déguisements ? Et les jouets ?
Chaque jour où ma fille se déguise,
elle apprend des choses qui,
selon un processus qui, dans mon propre travail,
professeur d'étude des médias,
nous appelons la pédagogie publique.
Cela désigne la façon dont les idéologies sont apprises aux sociétés.
Vous avez appris ce que c'est d'être un homme ou une femme,
de bien se comporter en public,
ce que c'est d'être patriote, d'avoir de bonnes manières.
Ce sont tous les relations sociales qui font de nous une personne.
En bref, c'est comment nous apprenons ce que nous savons des autres
et du monde.
Mais notre société est complètement saturée par les médias.
Cela signifie que chaque aspect de notre existence,
en dehors de nos fonctions corporelles basiques,
est influencé par les médias.
De votre voiture à votre alimentation
en passant par vos vêtements,
vos relations
et le langage employé pour exprimer vos pensées --
tout cela est, d'une certaine façon, influencé par les médias.
Dans notre société,
nous apprenons ce que nous savons des autres et du monde
en majorité à travers les médias.
Cela est problématique
car, dans notre société,
les médias ne sont pas simplement
des technologies de diffusion de l'information.
Ce sont également des entreprises.
Et quand la diffusion de l'information est liée aux gains financiers,
il y a un problème.
Quelle est son ampleur ?
Réfléchissez à ceci :
en 1983, 90% des médias américains appartenaient à 50 entreprises.
Pour tout marché, 50 entreprises représentent un nombre important.
Ce sont beaucoup de visions du monde.
En 2015, ce nombre a chuté à 6.
Six entreprises.
Il y NBC-Universal-Comcast, AOL-Time Warner,
Walt Disney, News Corp, Viacom et CBS Corporation.
Ces six entreprises produisent neuf films sur dix,
neufs séries télévisées sur dix, neuf chansons sur dix,
neuf livres sur dix.
Ma question est la suivante :
si six entreprises contrôlent 90% des médias américains,
à votre avis, quelle influence ont-elles sur ce que vous voyez au quotidien ?
En étude des médias,
nous disons que les médias ne peuvent pas nous dire quoi penser,
ils ne peuvent pas, ils sont mauvais à cela.
Ce n'est pas leur travail.
Les médias ne nous disent pas quoi penser,
ils nous disent à quoi penser.
Ils contrôlent la conversation
et, en contrôlant la conversation,
ils n'ont pas besoin que vous pensiez ce qu'ils veulent.
Ils vous feront réfléchir aux choses auxquelles ils veulent que vous pensiez
et, plus important, ne pas penser à ce qu'ils ne veulent pas.
Ils contrôlent la conversation.
Comment cela fonctionne-t-il ?
Prenons une des ces entreprises,
une facile.
Parlons de Walt Disney.
Je choisis toujours Walt Disney pour cette raison :
y a-t-il quelqu'un dans cette pièce n'ayant jamais vu un film Disney ?
Regardez autour de vous. Exactement.
J'ai choisi Disney car ils ont une pénétration de 100%
dans notre société.
Tout le monde a été exposé à Disney,
c'est donc facile pour moi.
Depuis 1937, Disney a gagné de l'argent en vendant des princesses aux filles.
Ils ont gagné beaucoup d'argent ainsi.
A moins que la princesse qui intéresse votre fille
ne soit celle-ci.
En 2012,
Disney a acheté LucasFilm pour la somme de 4 milliards de dollars,
ils ont immédiatement inondé les magasins Disney avec Han Solo,
Obi-Wan Kenobi, Dark Vador, Luke Skywalker et Yoda
mais pas avec la princesse Leia.
Pourquoi ? Car cette princesse détruit la pédagogie publique
de ces princesses.
Disney n'a donc pas mis de produits à l'effigie de la princesse Leia en vente
et quand les gens ont dit à Disney :
« Eh, où est la princesse Leia ? »
Disney a répondu ne pas avoir l'intention
de mettre en vente des produits à son effigie.
Les fans, en colère, ont inondé Twitter
avec le hashtag #OnVeutLeia.
Disney a alors dit que c'était une incompréhension.
Ce qu'ils voulaient dire, c'était
qu'ils n'avaient pas encore de produits à l'effigie de la princesse Leia.
C'était en 2012, nous sommes en 2015
et si vous allez dans un magasin Disney
et cherchez les produits à son effigie,
savez-vous combien vous trouverez d'articles dans le magasin Disney ?
Zéro, car Disney ne compte pas mettre la princesse Leia en magasin.
Cela ne devrait pas nous surprendre car nous savons que c'est leur politique
depuis le rachat de Marvel en 2009
pour la somme de 4,5 milliards de dollars.
Quand vous gagnez beaucoup d'argent en vendant des princesses aux filles,
vous voulez en gagner en vendant aux garçons.
Et pour cela, quoi de mieux que les super-héros ?
Disney a maintenant accès à Captain America, Thor,
l'incroyable Hulk
et ils ont même accès
à un groupe de super-héros inconnus du monde.
Marvel a bien vendu ses super-héros.
L'année dernière, ils ont sorti un film : « Les Gardiens de la Galaxie ».
Ce film ne devrait pas fonctionner.
Personne ne les connaissait, à part les accros de BD comme moi.
Un des personnages est un arbre qui parle.
Un autre est un raton-laveur anthropomorphique.
Cela ne devrait pas marcher.
« Les Gardiens de la Galaxie » a eu un grand succès.
Ce personnage au milieu s'appelle Gamora.
Elle est jouée par Zoe Saldana,
elle est forte, intelligente, rapide et se bat comme un ninja,
elle est jouée par une très belle femme noire
et ma fille en est tombée amoureuse.
Comme tout bon père geek, j'ai voulu acheter des trucs Gamora à ma fille,
je suis allé en magasin et j'ai appris un fait intéressant.
Si je voulais acheter un sac-à-dos Gamora,
Gamora n'est pas dessus.
Ils auraient dû l'étiqueter comme « un » des Gardiens de la Galaxie.
(Rires)
Si je voulais une boîte de déjeuner, elle n'était pas dessus.
Si je voulais un t-shirt,
elle n'était pas dessus.
En effet,
en allant au magasin, ce que j'ai fait,
et en regardant les présentoirs,
vous trouveriez ici une petite image de Gamora
mais si vous regardez les produits présents sur l'étagère,
Gamora n'est sur aucun d'entre eux.
J'aurais pu en parler sur Twitter avec le hashtag #OuEstGamora,
comme l'ont fait des millions de fans à travers le monde,
mais je n'étais pas réellement surpris
car j'étais là quand Disney a sorti « Avengers ».
Cette année, il y a eu un nouveau film des Avengers, « L'âge d'Ultron »,
nous étions excités
car il n'y avait pas une mais deux super-héroïnes :
la Sorcière Rouge et la Veuve Noire.
Nous étions très excités.
Mais voici la vérité à ce sujet.
Bien que Scarlett Johansson,
l'une des actrices les plus populaires en Amérique, joue la Veuve Noire
et qu'elle soit la star
de pas un, ni deux mais de cinq films de Marvel,
il n'y a aucun produit à l'effigie de la Veuve Noire en magasin.
Pas un seul.
Si vous cherchez un déguisement de la Veuve Noire dans un magasin Disney,
vous trouverez Captain America et l'incroyable Hulk.
Vous trouverez Iron Man et Thor.
Vous trouverez même War Machine
qui apparaît à peine dans le film.
Vous ne trouverez pas la Veuve Noire.
J'aurais pu faire comme beaucoup d'autres et aller sur Twitter
avec le hashtag #OuEstNatasha.
Mais j'en ai marre de faire cela.
J'en ai marre de devoir le faire.
Partout dans le pays
des enfants jouent avec les figurines du Cycle Blast Quinjet
où Captain America saute d'un avion à moto
et c'est vraiment génial.
Vous savez à quel point ?
Au point que, dans le film,
c'est Black Widow qui le fait.
Elle n'a pas seulement été effacée,
elle a été remplacée par un personnage masculin.
Qu'est-ce que cela nous apprend ?
Au cours des cinq prochaines années,
Disney, Warner Bros et quelques autres studios de cinéma
vont sortir plus de 30 longs métrages
avec des personnages de BD
et de ces 30 longs métrages,
exactement deux d'entre eux auront un personnage principal féminin.
Deux.
Il y aura des femmes de le reste de ces films
mais ce seront des acolytes, des dulcinées,
des membres de l'équipe,
pas des personnages principaux.
Et si nous apprenons ce que nous savons
sur les autres et le monde à travers les médias,
alors ces entreprises enseignent à ma fille que malgré qu'elle soit forte,
intelligente, rapide et qu'elle se batte comme un ninja,
les quatre sont vrais,
cela n'importe pas.
Elle sera ignorée comme Gamora
ou effacée et remplacée par un garçon
comme la Veuve Noire.
Ce n'est pas juste.
Ce n'est pas juste envers elle, ni envers vos fils et vos filles.
Voici le problème :
j'élève une petite fille et elle a un côté garçonne,
ce qu'il est terrible de dire en parlant d'une fille.
Ce que cela signifie c'est que ces traits la définissant,
ils ne sont pas à elle,
ils lui sont juste prêtés pendant un temps par des garçons.
Savez-vous combien de remarques elle aura durant sa vie
car elle a un côté garçonne ?
Zéro. Aucune.
Les gens trouvent cela mignon.
Ils la diront fougueuse car, dans notre société,
qu'une fille ait des traits masculins
est vu comme une amélioration, un bonus.
Je n'élève pas de petit garçon comme Mike.
Mike est un garçon vivant en Floride.
Il a 11 ans et ce qu'il aime le plus au monde
est une série : « Mon Petit Poney : les amies, c'est magique ».
Il en va de même pour des millions d'enfants américains.
La série est commercialisée pour les filles de 5 à 9 ans
mais il y a des millions de garçons
et d'hommes adultes
qui apprécient « Mon Petit Poney ».
Ils ont un club.
Ils s'appellent les Froneys,
les frères des poneys, les gars aimant les poneys.
Je suis l'un d'entre eux.
Et qu'apprenons-nous, Mike, moi
et des millions d'autres garçons et hommes
de ce monde féminin et efféminé de « Mon Petit Poney » ?
Nous apprenons à étudier, travailler dur, faire la fête,
avoir l'air beau, se sentir beau
et faire le bien,
que l'on nous préserve d'inculquer ces concepts de mauviettes aux garçons.
Les autres enfants du quartier embêtent et battent Mike,
ils se moquent de lui
et, à 11 ans, Mike rentre à la maison,
trouve une ceinture, la met autour de son cou
et se pend depuis son lit superposé.
Car nous avons développé une société
où l'on préfère être un garçon mort plutôt que d'aimer des trucs pour filles.
Ce n'est pas la faute de Mike, c'est notre faute.
Nous l'avons laissé tomber.
Nous avons laissé tombé nos enfants.
Pour eux, nous devons faire mieux.
Il ne faut plus que les seuls t-shirts sur lesquels apparaissent
des super-héroïnes ne soient pas roses et pour les filles.
Il faut arrêter.
Quand j'ai rassemblé ces idées, les gens me disaient :
« Cela n'arrivera jamais. » et je répondais « Vraiment ? »
Cette année seulement, Target a annoncé
qu'ils arrêteraient les rayons sexospécifiques.
Ils vont tout mélanger.
Avant de nous fatiguer à féliciter Target,
cette semaine ils ont sorti un t-shirt,
l'une des scènes emblématiques de « Star Wars : un nouvel espoir »
où la princesse Leia fait face au seigneur noir des Sith
est sur le t-shirt
mais Leia est mystérieusement remplacée par Luke.
Ne nous réjouissons pas trop.
Cette semaine également,
Disney a annoncé que les costumes d'Halloween ne seront plus sexospécifiques
et je réponds : « Merci, Disney
mais tous les costumes sont pour des super-héros masculins
alors qui les porte importe-t-il vraiment ? »
Cette semaine, Mattel, créateur de Barbie,
a annoncé la sortie d'une ligne de super-héroïnes DC.
Ce qui est marrant est
qu'ils ont rencontré des filles
pour savoir ce qu'elles voulaient comme poupées.
Vous le voyez, elles ont des mollets
et des coudes qui plient pour faire des trucs de super-héros.
Achetez-en, s'il vous plaît.
Mais pas juste pour vos filles,
achetez-en pour vos fils.
Il est important que les garçons jouent avec des super-héroïnes,
tout autant que ma fille joue avec des super-héros.
En effet, ce que j'aimerais voir,
c'est un monde où toute personne allant dans un magasin
y aille avec un organigramme en tête
expliquant si le jouet est pour un garçon ou une fille.
Cet organigramme est très simple car il n'y a qu'une question :
« Ce jouet fonctionne-t-il grâce à vos organes génitaux ? »
(Rires)
Si la réponse est oui,
ce n'est pas un jeu pour enfants.
(Rires)
Si la réponse est non,
alors c'est pour les garçons et les filles.
C'est très simple.
Aujourd'hui, nous parlons du futur du futur et dans mon futur
les garçons et les filles sont autant respectés,
autant estimés et, le plus important, autant représentés.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)